as you know Donald Trump has fired the
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson whether
it was because of Russia or to protect
Jared Kushner we don't quite know we
might never know but what we do know is
that Ivanka Trump the president's
daughter whose band by nepotism laws
from having a formal position in the
administration is sitting in for the
Secretary of State at an upcoming
meeting with the South Korean Foreign
Minister and the White House is
confirming this the White House is
saying yeah Ivanka who as I told you
last week is still set to her in about a
million dollars this year from the Trump
family business from which she has not
separated herself she will be meeting
with Kang kumoi of South Korea
not only does Ivanka Trump not have a
formal position in the White House
because she can't not only does she have
business interests in the country of
South Korea from which she still is
going to earn money she doesn't even
have a permanent security clearance
presumably because of the problems with
Jared Kushner and multiple false sf-86
vetting form submissions and she is
going to be doing something that would
typically be the purview of the
Secretary of State in related news a
panel of Bachelor contestants as well as
the Long Island medium that psychic
woman are going to be filling in from
Mike Pompeo a CIA director while he goes
through the process of becoming separate
separate Secretary of State how low are
we going to go here am I being too tough
on Ivanka like can we say that because
she designs some really nice handbags oh
wait a second no they actually paid
someone else to design the handbags I
might prefer the actual Ivanka handbag
designer / Ivanka meet with the South
Korean foreign minister all joking aside
this is probably illegal okay there's a
piece of law so we've got the
anti-nepotism laws which say why Ivanka
can't have an official position in the
government there's something else called
inherently governmental functions which
is five u.s. code 31:10 subsection
employment of relatives which
specifically says there are certain
government functions that are so
intimately related to the public
interest that they can only
be performed by a government employee
this has to be adjudicated right this is
subjective but how can anyone argue that
the functions of the Secretary of State
are not inherently governmental
functions Ivanka Trump is a private
citizen and thus should be forbidden
from participating in these functions
and yet she is and it appears to violate
that law it appears as though there may
be other violations emoluments questions
so much of what's going on here and part
of this of course has to do with the
broader problem of just unfilled
positions in the Trump administration
two-thirds of the top nine jobs meaning
six of the top nine jobs at the State
Department are currently empty this is
not normal and I keep going back to this
point the real tragedy of the Trump
debacle is that it has made ignorant
popular again okay it's put a ton of
energy behind those who defend lack of
knowledge and lack of intellectual
curiosity and it goes way beyond the
micro of Ivanka sitting there as
Secretary of State or Trump paying a
porn star off or Trump being the puppet
of a foreign government we can undo a
lot of the damage that Trump does some
of it we won't be able to undo but it's
going to take a long time to recover
from the broader idea that speaking like
Trump doing diplomacy or not doing it
the way the Trump administration is
doing it these pseudo intellectualism
and anti intellectualism that I've been
talking about for a while now that has
lasting damage just look at education
around the world look at math and
science scores from other countries
compared to the United States that is
going to be in my mind the most
long-term destructive impact of the
Trump administration and I I don't
exactly know how we're going to recover
from it I'm out of time no voicemail
today it was gonna be a good one it
really was but I'll get to it tomorrow
fantastic bonus show coming up for you
today as well today's program is
sponsored by new underwriter shaker and
spoon this is very quickly becoming one
of my favorite things shaker and spoon
is a monthly cocktail subscription box
that delivers a craft
cocktail experience to your door it's
sort of like blue apron for cocktails
and I don't really know that much about
cocktails when I go to a bar I basically
order a vodka soda
when I make a drink at home I basically
make a vodka soda I just don't really
know anything and the great thing about
how shaker and spoon works is that every
month they send you the ingredients with
no alcohol so it's your call whether you
want to make these with or without
alcohol they send you three original
cocktail recipes created by the
bartenders that they work with and all
of the ingredients you need except the
alcohol which you go and buy if you want
or you make the drinks non-alcoholic
they give you video tutorials you get
one box a month which lasts the entire
month 12 cocktails and what I really
like about it is that number one some of
the ingredients that go into cocktails
are not necessarily ingredients you
would use in a lot of cooking so I don't
necessarily want to buy a ton of
unground nutmeg if I don't use that in
cooking because it's just gonna sit
around and in my shaker and spoon box
which was a gin-based cocktail box it
came with enough nutmeg for the drinks
that require nutmeg it came with enough
rock salt and other stuff limes lemons
etc some of the drinks are complex some
of them are more simple they all come
with really easy to follow directions
and I've been having a great time with
it I encourage you to check it out go to
shaker and spoon dot-com slash Pakman
that's fully spelled out shaker a ND
spoon dot-com forward slash Pakman and
that will save you 20 bucks off of your
first box